[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quite Riga and our focus this week is on
dramatic developments here in German
politics the grand coalition government
in Berlin has been thrown into disarray
by the resignation of the leader of the
Social Democrats the junior coalition
partner Andrea nihilus her announcement
that she was throwing in the towel came
after a disastrous showing for the SPD
in the recent European election
Chancellor Merkel said she regretted the
decision but pledged that her government
would somehow soldier on critics though
are not convinced saying the end is nigh
for the coalition and that would also
spell the end for the Chancellor so a
question here on quadriga this week his
coalition crisis Merkel teetering and to
answer that question I'm joined here in
the studio by journalist and author
andreas glute who says in effect Angela
Merkel neurons a caretaker government
with no residual ambition at all that is
tragic for Germany and tragic for Europe
indeed also with us is Vanessa vu from
sight online who argues that the ruling
coalition is shying away from a reset as
she puts it in the end this might harm
both parties and our democracy and a
very warm welcome to Turk or dollar
taught from the business we cleaver
chops Baha who believes grand
coalition's disrupts the traditional
party system and so do huge shifts
within the electorate very interesting
statements thank you all three for being
with me here on quadriga this week I'd
like to begin with you cordula
a lot going on here in Berlin at the
moment talk of crisis in the government
why are people saying that the
government's days are numbered oh I
wouldn't say that the days you can
already count after for the next
elections to come up but this government
is now buying time and there is not too
much probably to expect to be taken from
this government anymore so from what
you're saying the foreign view foreign
countries and foreign into international
partners of Germany who are looking on
at the current situation they can rest
assured that
Angela Merkel has a steady hand on the
tiller whether the government is more or
less functioning as usual yes they are
functioning they're managing yes but
they're not they are just trying to buy
time to find out who's going to lead the
Social Democrats which is the next step
there are interested in and before that
which is probably only after the
elections in the East because they're
all quite afraid of what is going to
happen in the East not much is going to
happen
Vanessa do you buy into all this angle
of government Angela Merkel's government
has been described as a coalition of the
desperate and you have said that it's
potentially a threat to our democracy
that sounds a lot more dramatic and
threatening indeed I think it's a
coalition of losers because the fact
that they have lost a lot of voices lots
of people don't really want this kind of
government anymore and the longer they
keep the power I think they will just
harm themselves in the end and not
really bring up the reforms that
everybody urgently needs mm-hmm Andres I
would like to bring you in but first of
all I'd like to go to a statement from a
man called DITA Kemp he is the infernal
influential president you're nodding
Andres he's the president of the
Federation of German industries the BDI
and he didn't mix his words when he
described a growing mood of crisis
surrounding Angela Merkel's fourth
government let's listen to what he had
to say and then we'll hear from andreas
midfield either Damon a lot of the
issues the grand coalition addresses do
not or no longer reach a large majority
of the total but coalition government
let me make this very clear has gambled
away a lot of trust
push beat
the coalition government has gambled
away a lot of trust that's pretty strong
words is this a dangerous time for
people in government to be rocking the
boat and not dangerous but the the
problem with the trust is that the
German economy is supposed both the
Mittal's Tonto family-owned firms and
the larger the listed Ducks firms they
are very unhappy because they're simply
pointing out what everyone knows that
the there hasn't been any meaningful
domestic reform under Merkel ever then
the last big reform was a labor market
reform under her predecessor since then
she's managed very effectively several
international crises but she's done
nothing at home and there are big
problems having to do with investments
that are too low Germany has been
investing too little both public and
private sector there's the big issue of
China and America and little Germany in
Europe getting ground up between them
there's already official intelligence
and the digital transformation word the
German economy is behind and now there's
climate change and energy and all these
other things so there's a lot of things
that should be happening that you know
that are masked by the the putative
success of the German economy which
could be shouldn't be taken for granted
ever and that's why a lot of managers a
lot of business owners business
entrepreneurs are very upset because
nothing's being done you have been not
in court enough well it was always the
big strength of Angela Merkel being good
at reacting being with the balancing
that's her kind of leadership hmm but
now I think we are quite at some point
that that is comparable to the point
that her predecessor Yehuda was at he
had we remember maybe it was sick man of
Europe Germany isn't working all these
things and he had it's huge labor market
reform we're still seeing the profits of
that and now we're in a situation that
Angela Merkel should react and the
latest election results are a big sign
now do something climate change is not
just about having a price on carbon and
having some tax maybe it's about
restructuring the whole economy and she
should be bold
now taking the step taxes all the
industry will be changed if you go on
that path a sense here Vanessa of what
is at stake here in Germany what is in
it at stake in Europe in this crisis we
can see in each country populism rising
especially the right-wing populism and I
think that Germany now has to be strong
show that we can be like a modern
working society that can also tackle
climate crisis and stay open while not
letting a right-wing populist and just
populist take over so this is what is at
stake now because I believe when Germany
becomes even more not less stable and
just dealing with all those little
things then we cannot stop this wider
movement so the crisis we're talking
about came about because of Germany's
Social Democrats hemorrhaging support
but angular Merkel's Christian Democrats
are also under huge pressure they too
suffered a demoralizing setback in the
recent European election for many years
now of course the Conservatives main
asset their unique selling point has
been one person who we've mentioned
already after keeping a low profile in
recent months Chancellor Merkel has
reemerged
and is acting as a pillar of strength we
will continue the government's work with
all due seriousness and above all with a
great sense of responsibility last
December Angela Merkel handed over
responsibility for leading her party the
CDU to an agreed camp Karen Bower she
was to continue Merkel's legacy and
succeed her as Chancellor in two years
time the Christian Democrats have little
to offer young people worried about
climate change that's clear from the
success of this protest video by blogger
reso
if adding video in this video I'll show
you how folks from the CDU live how they
lack the basic skills to do their jobs
and how they're wrecking our lives and
future job his video the destruction of
the CDU has racked up almost 15 million
views but the CDU has yet to come up
with a cogent response the Chancellor's
current crisis management is a far cry
from her we can do this dance back in
2015 our new parliamentary elections on
the horizon in Germany
lots of talk of fresh elections lots of
talk about from America not being able
to contain the crisis as she lost her
magic touch that kill has kept her in
power for so long how has she lost it
that's a very good question I don't
think that she has really lost it I
think many people still appreciate this
woman but in the end she just managed a
lot of crises and she didn't bring up
very she didn't tackle the big questions
and the big questions that are now
coming to the streets and the big
questions that now the youth is
addressing for example is well
everything this government did in the
past year since and they are in power
like 2005 is that they corrected these
little things politics yes they may
tweak this and that and then I think and
now people that just have this bigger
questions rising and saying hey what
happened in the past like 10 years and
and where are the bigger issues going
the world is changing so fast and why
are you not really dealing with these so
the question is then Andrea says why is
Angela Merkel acting effectively as a
sort of a parallel German Foreign
Minister on the international stage very
visible but at home he's failing to
tackle the the the problems that you
have both all three been talking about
here well the the immediate reason is
that she's she made herself a lame-duck
by stepping back when they were by the
way you just mentioned it what has she
lost her touch as Vanessa just said she
hasn't lost her magic touch at all she's
been in power so many years and she's
still there and she probably will still
to anagram Karen Bowa and she stood
there very close to I mean to kiss stick
with the metaphor to actually dropping
the battle well there's a problem that
we have to start talking about with
Annika kamboja that great long German
name akk but while you're talking about
Merkel she is doing this optimally she's
doing this as skillfully as you can in
her position do this I don't know CDU
Chancellor before her has done it this
well they all were voted out or kicked
out or pushed out and we were talking
we've been talking since 2015 about her
being pushed out and he or she
still lives and won one thing she did
was that tactical decision last December
- she preempted a coup that she heard
about by stepping back from the chair
the chairmanship of the her party - with
the intention that akk got it
akka had to fight for it and with the
intention that she could now groom or
that akk could do basically do a long
internship to become Angela Merkel
wasn't born Chancellor either if you go
back to her early years as minister and
then as party leader she she she had a
lot of learning to do as well and so she
knows akka has to do that
akka is less popular now than Merkel is
German still like Merkel she's also less
known and she's struggling in bid now
but but that's what they're gonna work
on is basically give her an internship
because you're breaking a lance here for
angular Merkel and saying that she's
she's still pretty much on course but at
the top of the show we had you saying
Angela Merkel is at the helm of her
caretaker government with no residual
ambition I was always talking to her
Meditec just simply her ability to stay
in power okay now the question is she
doing anything with that power and you
already heard that from cordula she
hasn't really done much with her power
all these years so the last big reform
was her under her predecessor except for
Migration but except for well two
decisions on one on nuclear power which
probably was the wrong one as we're as
we get into climate we'll have to talk
about is it was it this debate is coming
up was it smart to exit nuclear power
before coal generated power is there
they're going to talk about that and
then the big one was on migration in
2015 that's true so that she has left a
legacy but no there's there's a lot of
problems that she can't deal with
because she's a lame duck she did that
intentionally tactically to hold on to
power okay enough about Angela Merkel
for just a moment cordula
tell us about the backdrop to a lot of
what we're talking about here is this
notion of the German Fulks part iron and
the idea that they are in pretty much
terminal demise what do you make of all
that and can you explain it a little bit
for our viewers well this traditional
system is probably history now the
latest European election results have
shown that
traditionally and in post-war Germany
West Germany and now complete Germany we
had two camps center right center left
and two big parties one a little more to
the right the christian democrats and
one little bit more to the left the
social democrats and the idea was that
these two parties always could get a
majority and that they had different
concepts and if one government was not
delivering anymore the other could take
over and having these three grand
coalition's with Angela Merkel already
this whole idea is now just not working
anymore because Angela Merkel has turned
to the left cheese of Social Democrats
some people in her party say and this is
not a positive thing in her party and on
the other hand we had before Garuda who
also turned to the right and was doing
something his own electorate wasn't
really saying was good thing so these a
whole idea is now not working anymore
and we don't have any probably any new
parties that give us an idea how it
could work mm-hmm
so the traditional German party is being
swept aside to a certain extent Vanessa
bye-bye tectonic changes there and among
those two there's a lot of talk about
another tectonic change in German
politics suddenly the social media
people are having an influence on German
politics it's being described as a new
generation in German politics is that
all hype or is there something in it I
think there is something in it and I and
I wouldn't say social media but people
who are very savvy on communication they
know how communication works they know
how to how to get lots of followers how
to which words to use to really reach a
wider audience
the younger ones those who are not well
educated and so on and so on and so they
are all quite young but prose and what
they do and they just sneak into the
political discourse and we see that the
major parties are really failing at
understanding them and also in
adequately reacting to it because they
seem so helpless
they don't even know what to do with
those kids on the street for example
they don't know what to do with this
reserva do they they try to to answer
them by their own videos but these do
not really work because they know there
is simply not an experience in it it's
not part of their language when we talk
about big parties in demise that it
doesn't quite apply across the board
because the new the new big force in
German politics according to a polls
from just a couple of days ago it's the
greens they are now the strongest party
in German politics according to that one
poll where does that come from then
Andres comes that is the direct counter
to the rise the the preceding rise of
the alternative for Germany because
what's happened is you you have this old
left-right spectrum that cordula
described through most of post-war West
German history but then a new spectrum
as in other countries in the entire West
and from France Australia everywhere
which is open closed in the alternative
for Germany especially after the big
migration year 2015 was the it took the
clear stance for a closed society
especially towards foreigners and
migrants now of all the other parties
the Greens are the ones who took the
clearer stance for an open society and
so you saw that the the people who
wanted a clear message of closed went
for the AFD but it's stuck nationally at
about 13% and higher in the East but the
people who want who definitely wanted to
plump for open they went to the Greens
the Free Democrats the Liberal Party
could have played that role but didn't
so the Greens have now also come to
personify to embody openness and that
explains their rise in the recent years
and the question is can they rise even
more and even become the strongest party
has one poll showed mm-hmm the Greens
are often accused now when when when the
other party was looking at their success
they're accused of being a sort of a one
policy party do you buy into that no no
definitely they're not I'd even say
they're a bit nerdy because they're
always trying to come up with concepts
and be prepared to take over some kind
of part of government so no they're
probably not one one issue party anymore
they are strong
with climate change and they're strong
with all the environmental questions and
they know that they always have to be a
bit ahead of all the other parties they
have to be a bit avant-garde and come up
with new ideas they're not always tested
these new ideas and also talking about
climate change it's not that they really
have given us a clear idea how they
would do it but in a way they're always
trying to be prepared and be part of an
extra government so suddenly climate
politics are it seems the dominant
political narrative in Germany well not
quite because people in large numbers
tend to do things very differently in
the Eastern German states Western
Germany is going green all over the
Green Party is more popular than ever
especially with young voters the greens
are achieving results Germany's major
political parties can only dream of
[Music]
in the east of the country the
right-wing populists alternative for
Germany is growing stronger in many
places they could be the big winners in
upcoming state elections but most of
Germany's big cities including some in
the East are Green Party bastions for
urbanites climate protection is a major
priority they want eco friendly traffic
concepts and clean energy coal mining is
being phased out to tackle global
warming many in the affected areas
consider this a big mistake and fear for
their jobs to them environmental
protection is a luxury only rich city
folk can afford so who can bring the
country together Vanessa who can bring
the country together I don't think the
Greens are particularly failing so for
now they're attracting this urban
intellectual elite but I believe that
and this is what also the Green Party
always keeps saying and they are working
on this very hard is that the green
question or the environmental question
is also a social question because when
we look at who is suffering from from
climate change for example yes of course
there's but there are those coal miners
but first of all this is a small number
we can find solutions for them a
globally these are completely different
people these are the poorest people we
have here and they will migrate when the
climate changes and also here in the
cities we do have to find like other
solutions on how to move how to be more
inclusive about mobility how to use
energy differently so that we can just
keep on living as we live longer or more
sustainable and I think that greens can
tackle these questions another thing
what they do is protecting minority
rights now we know that there has not
too many minorities in the former East
but in the end they also protect from
they also profit from this discourse
because it's all about protecting the
poorer ones for example those who are
forgotten those who need more
representation all of these questions
are inherently also green issues corrala
you have been quoted as saying that the
East and West are more divided than
before I don't know if you meant ever
for all more recently but tell me about
the divide because it's gonna be crucial
and what happens next in German politics
you mentioned this already earlier now
there's less common ground now as
election results show and it's quite
difficult to get your idea across in the
east and and you could also argue that
in the east well there is a lot of rural
folks and people have to to drive longer
to get to work and all these things and
they live probably in other apartments
it's difficult to have a climate
friendly policy because it's more more
expensive for the people there it's hard
to get this idea across that they will
still profit from it so and people they
feel maybe a second time left behind or
not really taken seriously like in the
90s like every family there was one or
more people who lost their jobs and they
had really to have a huge modernization
to take and now when the middle
generation is gone already the young
people moved to the metropolitan areas
or to the West the people that are left
behind in huge areas in in big regions
they they think what is coming who's
who's trying to take care of us what's
next for us we would like to have a
share as well and they're not really the
best ideas yet in place there's one
other aspect of thing in the East the
eastern Germans didn't grow up with the
West German political parties these of
big tent parties the center left's in a
red block even the Greens they're
essentially the in a way the most
Western party the party that there is
they joined the Bundestag the Parliament
in the 1980s they came out of the West
German counterculture of the 60s and 70s
all of this the Easterners didn't have
and that's why you have two parties that
are unusually strong in East Germany and
really only in East Germany which are
both protest parties one is the
successor the left the successor party
or the descendant of the East German
Communist Party and the other is the aft
which in the east both of them and that
there are is there are even voter
migrations between them and between non
voters but they're essentially a lot of
them are just giving a middle finger to
that political party system as they see
it
which they still view as a West German
part party system to some extent I would
totally agree there and but I think the
problem is not then that they rely on
the car or eat lots of meat but then the
problem is a problem of representation
and this is where the parties really
have to work on and see how many
politicians from the east we have in our
parties how much are they dealing with
the issues that they have there and
these are the things that really have to
be tackled at the moment to not just let
them stick with the AFD and the Left
Party and we have these key regional
elections coming up in eastern Germany
and in the autumn in September and
October do you think that that is going
to be a point at which the German
government really does fall apart
because a lot of people are predicting
that the results are going to be so
damaging for democracy in Germany that's
going to push the current government
over the edge yes definitely and I don't
see how how now we can I don't think
that that is now the moment where we can
change a lot I think we'll just turn out
as everybody expects the the right-wing
AFD especially they will be very strong
and so on but we have to ask ourselves
the the bigger questions behind us like
what exactly happened there how do we
tackle the misrepresentation how can we
put more money into this area and where
do they also which we must not forget
and have a really a logic problem and I
think this is always hard to say because
they will defend themselves and say like
we're not all Nazis but we have we see
that there are organized right-wing
extremist groups operating there very
big networks and they have lots of money
they're going and talk to especially the
small towns they have power in those
regions and this is something we should
not like ignore and say there are only a
few of those coal miners and other
people who have social or poorer we've
got to close now I'm going to ask one
question we've began with Angela Merkel
is she going to be in office at the end
of the year yes or no Andras general
elections may be in January
I think she will stir stick stay for a
while okay we shall have to wait and see
as they say coalition crisis Merkel
teetering thanks for joining us on quad
riga this week bye bye for now and chess
[Music]